graceful flock of swans beat you over
the head with picturesque symbolism
Nicholas Sparks hunt
I guess this dude didn't get his
medication for the day I'm really gonna
miss that guy after the promise of young
romance in the trailer movie spends the
first several minutes hitting you over
the head with old people oh right now
where did we leave cruel husband asks
wife with dementia where they left off
during pointless love story also movie
rips off the old person is reading this
entire story to someone else gimmick
from The Princess Bride do you mind
Ferris wheel guy breaks the rules by
stopping the ride when Noah's at the top
to scold him for breaking the rules in
the head oh she didn't hear that well
this couldn't possibly make the
situation more dangerous after this Noah
somehow got down from the ferris wheel
unharmed Noah and Allie parted ways with
an exchanging phone numbers and there
was no further discussion whatsoever
yeah sure mr. underwear yes the most
memorable thing about Noah hanging from
that ferris wheel and practically
threatening suicide was the exposed
underwear moment I was being drawn to
you but a line girls the preceding
dialogue was brought to you by cliche
when you need a line make it a cliche
earlier James Garner said the carnival
was June 6 1944 the summer but when Noah
finally gets his date it's to see Lil
Abner which didn't come out until
November 1st 1940 after you gee she made
him sit on the other side of the couple
I wasn't alive in 1940 but the strikes
me is the very definition of playing
hard to get the town was bustling with
activity but respectfully cleared the
fuck out for Ali and Noah's post movie
walk
Radcliff sarah lord of the going to ally
expertly plays the pronoun game so that
no one has to ask what we means is we
what ah well played she is brilliant at
this game dad nice to come out here lay
down watch the lights change oh come on
I mean even in the 1930s and 40s this
had to be one of the most pointless
things to do with your time go green red
yellow um if they went from green to red
to yellow you were watching broken
lights when Noah first lays down he's on
the centerline but then when Ali leans
down with him first there all the way
over solidly in one lane then in a
subsequent shot they're back over in the
other Lane basically I look at this car
almost hit them if they're lying on the
other Lane was the English also the guy
in the car has every right to be mad but
was he really not gonna stop for any
reason or even swerved to miss them that
was a lovely poem what was it rich girl
who has millions of tutors and looking
to attend Radcliffe or Sarah Lawrence
doesn't recognize Leaves of Grass by
Walt Whitman also she could hear Noah
reading the poem in a low mumble but not
hear his dad say not bad for witness
from wetland I'm a Tennyson man myself
that he likes Whitman well this sounds
like an epic rap battle in the making
now say you're a bird too if you're a
bird I'm a bird and this is me giving
you the bird everything about this poor
people hoedown is completely authentic
especially the part about how their
clothes are spotless poor people always
dress to the nines for a hoedown Oh
Brenda Leigh with that bowing down line
Juliet's dad waits until 30 dates have
gone by before bothering to notice
there's a Romeo in his daughter's life
okay
scene does not contain a lap dance there
I said it yeah let's go to the haunted
house to have sex I think going back to
the traffic lights to have sex would
have been safer this is a good way to
drain your battery and get stuck out in
the middle of nowhere I'm gonna buy it
one damn oh this must be It's a
Wonderful Life section of the rip-off
fest is this really the first time
they're gonna have sex damn they waited
like the whole summer to do this
oh dude I mean seriously dude I know
it's an emergency but you couldn't knock
first
parents are going crazy they got every
cop in town out looking for how long
were they taking off their clothes they
only left on their gain a little bit ago
drove to this house chatted and then
started disrobing that her parents wait
a whole 15 minutes before calling the
cops
he wrote one letter a day for a year and
every single time Ali's mom beat her to
the mailbox you think a girl like Ali
would have been desperate to check the
mail every day for at least a month and
would have been suspicious if her mother
said not to go near the mailbox for any
risky and fit pack their bags and head
in frigid oh so now you're ready to go
to the big city go to New York with your
hot girlfriend no but go to Atlanta with
your BFFs sure man this two-minute
montage scene perfectly encapsulates
what it must have been like to be in the
war why the hell did I mother watching
always being a brother's episode did she
just wake him up sit him up pretend to
think about maybe giving him a sip of
water and then lay him back down on the
bed I guess that's why she's a volunteer
nurse stalking she agreed with all her
heart but couldn't understand why at the
very moment she said yes Noah's face
came to her mind because no one falls in
love with James Marsden in movies and
gets away with it
Noah took a look at the house but only
saw one thing Ali because no one falls
in love with the house in movies and get
paid stamp ticket dealt him a sweet car
well either fate or the screenwriter Ali
just happens to be in the exact place
where Noah's started to give up looking
for also is it just me or is fate
getting lazy here I mean no almost
missed her completely shall not want
when Noah's father died we did Duke skip
a whole chapter where Noah's father
becomes some sort of disease or
something I mean the dude didn't die of
old age that's for sure geez dude just
take the house off the market also did
Noah tell this couple to negotiate the
price of the house next to his truck so
that he could pull a shotgun on them
just in case they offered too much money
a woman knows when a man looks into her
eyes and sees a woman um based on my
experience no she doesn't
wedding porn this newspaper took several
days possibly weeks to run the store it
hasn't Noah been trying to sell this
house for a while or did all those
people who came by his house come on one
day also what kind of newspaper puts
Society news house restorations models
paying traffic fines and a Frenchman
wins prize story all on the same page
also there's a ton of news
Spiro Agnew and Barry Goldwater in this
newspaper even though their political
career started well after this time
period this is a good way to destroy a
veil take care of a few things need to
clear my head pretty amazing that lawn
doesn't realize this is code for I'm
going to bang my old boyfriend before I
marry kar conveniently doesn't start
after hitting a wooden fence so that
Ally can officially cheat on law this is
a good story movie pimps its own story I
think I've heard it before
yeah we all have just has different
actors in it Jane Steiners arms go from
uncross to crossed in these subsequent
shots this way yep this is the room
where you talk too much while you were
naked and nobody got laid by the way
how'd your father die no one seems to
know what about how her car was wrecked
on the fence come home mama doesn't know
us wait a minute you mean Noah and Allie
got back together
you ruined it for me all this time I
thought she was gonna end up a lawn well
I don't need to watch this movie anymore
to him anything you want to tell me no
no no okay I see a fiancee her doormat
did he already fix that fence this scene
would be a lot more believable that had
more geese and swans honestly why did
the director stop at this number it
completely kills my suspension of
disbelief I mean I can still see
sections of water we had to cut us in
here about a pearl necklace no sin on
the counter for this scene we just
wanted to take a moment and tell you
that we do have limits kind of Noah's
shirt went through the Ryan Gosling
effect where it just disappears from one
room to the next at least thinking right
about now why didn't I have sex with
more poor people where the hell is Ali's
car we saw her leave it right where the
red car is currently sitting back when
she arrived yesterday and then they went
out on the boat got caught in the rain
ran straight inside to do it so when did
anyone move Ali's car was it the same
farmland who Beluga ferries that fix
offense
wait just a second they woke up from all
night long talked about eating breakfast
heard a knock at the door invited the
booty call girl in to eat with them and
now it's night time did she stay all
damn day in that house how many meals
did they cook for her reading also
there's no way this is a guy's
handwriting especially a rugged
craftsman and former wood mill worker
like Noah who basically rebuilt an
entire house by himself he does not have
penmanship this good also it's nothing
like the penmanship he showed on the
letters he was sending to Ali I didn't
want to wake but I'd risk waking you by
painstakingly sticking these arrows onto
the floor also did he's glue these
arrows onto the rug in the next room
none of these things flap up when she
runs past them so they're either stuck
there or they're painted there and man
that rug really tied the roomba gaps
mother who has been dead set against her
daughter dating an unsuitable poor guy
also dated an unsuitable poor guy when
she was young and now she's okay with it
cliche discount long distance L Fester's
to Luna Ali's mom is a hoarder I mean
she kept these letters for seven years
even after Ali got engaged to lawn and
for what what are you gonna do out you
don't know you don't know you just spent
several days in a row sleeping with this
guy and living with him and you're still
not sure what your heart wants you have
two incredible men to choose from choose
damn it and at least let one of them be
free to go snag some other girl before
they're gone
damn selfish much I'm not bitter anymore
because I know that what we had was real
so if it wasn't real you'd be bitter
oh damn sorry Martha you were this close
to getting him back
James Garner's cry-face this light
switch in this very dark room is turned
to the on position they're dead went
really tied up the character arcs they
didn't it I think the deaths are totally
necessary to the story and not just some
slapped on emotional tactic by a
director desperate to make you cry so
can I ask a question was there a
notebook anywhere in this story I mean
sure he's reading a handwritten story to
her but no one ever mentions a notebook
no one refers to this storybook as the
notebook we don't even get to see her
write the story in the notebook as a
younger girl I can't see a single reason
to call this movie the notebook that's
how not important the notebook was to
the actual story they could just as
easily have called this movie the old
house or lots of swans or the fence that
repaired itself all those things had
more symbolic impact on the story than
the notebook did
ah
now say you're a bird to your bird I'm a
bird you go meet you bud so I can say
fuck with me
a bird so what do you do know I work my
way from place to place
you know tramp steamers and such well
that's lovely dear
hmm come on by asking that how much do
you make it your job got air in my lungs
and a few blank sheets of paper just the
other night I was sleeping under a
bridge and now here I am on the grandest
ship in the world having champagne with
you fine people fix my
is it Vail too much are you kidding
you know what's better than watching a
movie about someone reading a story to
someone nothing listening to someone
read it Ted Ted a junior and now because
of the immense 150,000 title library
found at audible.com slash cinemasins
you can actually get the note book on
audiobook there's a version narrated by
Barry Bostwick do you know who that is
that's the mayor from Spin City
hey there citizens ooh hey there
citizens
there's a version with Kate Milligan who
I don't know in Campbell Scott that's
the dude for a single I was just nowhere
near their neighborhood if you look hard
enough you might even find an audio copy
of the fence that repaired itself this
Valentine's Day gift your sweetheart or
drown your single sorrows with a good
book about love I love you right now if
you head to audible.com slash cinemasins
and sign up for a trial membership you
can get your first book for free so what
are you waiting for get your audible
audiobook today and leave the reading to
the professionals
Shuki sure peace really